top of the division for a specific
reason not just because we have nothing
else to talk about there's a new update
in the near future update 1.4 which i'll
let you describe a little more but
basically a lot of like quality of life
changes but right now it's in public
test servers for on you play not steam
yet the Ubisoft said it would be on
steam soon enough I don't know it's not
in their words but so tell me is this
like what's up with the update why would
this bring people back why are we
talking about the division again yeah I
think the big thing going on in the
division right now is so they delayed
their dlc survival and last stand and
they're trying to get the core game hook
as good as they can a lot of things
they've done or they're testing right
now our quality of life improvements on
the shooting side they're trying to
lower time to kill they're trying to
drop loot that's more relevant to your
level and sort of do that destiny thing
where you slowly grind your way up at a
pace and they're like increasing ammo
like I think a lot of what they're
trying to get away from on the shooting
side is just where you you literally run
out of ammo trying to kill somebody
which is just kind of a boring way to
play a shooter yea though I mean it
seemed very much like destiny when I
first played a in the fact that it was
kind of more of an MMO to me because the
shooting mechanics the third person
mechanics felt good but it was more of
like bullet sponge enemies and like Luke
gear and whatnot but I don't know I I
was wondering how much more they would
need to do for this to actually become
like that people are someone had said
it's kind of like the taken King like
you'd said the way you're kind of just
grinding for like levels now instead of
going for these specific exotic items
etc yeah and I you know I think you know
again like if you're gonna have an MMO
that's a shooter you have to start with
the best shooting right or else you
don't have anything which destiny has
really good mechanics the reason that
destiny I think the reason that people
stuck with destiny for so long as a as a
like year-long beta test up until taken
king was that the core shooting was so
good that it was worth sticking around
to see what happened with the loot
system because like destiny was a game
where you got to a boss after a long
game and you shot them and nothing came
out right it was just totally busted
loot system Division it was like a very
similar feel you just didn't feel like
you were gaining much of anything as you
wait if you played the game kind of
casually as it was meant to be played if
you were willing to get into the whole
resource grind like you know something
like a arte did then you could probably
get what you were looking out of it that
sense of satisfaction but don't know
forgot like me I'm a shooter fan I was
looking for good shooting mechanics and
time to kill was a big issue the other
big issue which they have not addressed
in this patch yet or they've not
addressed in the public test is just
enemy lack of enemy reaction right so if
enemies run at you with high-powered
weapons it's a cover based shooter and
you are the only one who has to take
cover and if they're running straight at
you and they don't stagger or have fear
or do much of anything except for a
couple of weapons like the LMG where
they'll suppress then like what do you
have you don't really have a cover based
shooter right you just have a game where
people charge at you and kill you at
point-blank range yeah like the few
hours i did play it was infuriating that
people with baseball bats could run up
to me and I could put ten bullets in
them they'd still be alive one hit from
that baseball bat would kill me yeah
like what is a very very off-topic
tangent but I remember that's one reason
like one of the reason like resin evil 6
because like for the first time the
series when you shoot zombie they're not
reacting yeah and I didn't feel like
there's any impact and I want to in a
shooter i want to feel at impact like
destiny you get the headshots a lot of
times your head explodes like you get
they drop an item you know you kind of
when you knife them they go flying it
makes sense it feels like you're
actually affecting the enemies in the
game world and i remember that too
because i just i was watching the health
bar not the enemy as i was just
unloading magazine after magazine into
them and i guess my question is what
this pushed the dlc back like you were
saying survival the next plan one is
like later this year at some point and
last stand is next year now 2017 do you
think this update will be worth getting
into or do you think people are still
better off waiting for the dlc i think
what's going to bring people back is the
dlc and i'm guessing that their
intention is that they'll retain those
people with better quality of life so
they're also making other things easier
in this game so in addition to two new
content that they made and may or may
not be good i don't know like that's
still up to them they're doing small
things like you know weapon skins used
to take up all your inventory space so
if you wanted cool skins for your
weapons you have to give up like
tangible items in the game
they didn't have basic stuff like bulk
conversion at crafting stations that
they're trying to get in now so you
would spend like tons of time pressing
each one to break it down and the big
one that that is a big deal for me as
locking items which is something that's
been in destiny for a while but you
could very easily have accidentally
deleted a lot of your high level gear in
this game if you mark a bunch of stuff
to delete it to break it down but you
were accidentally clicked on your gun
that you are using which is common and
you hit delete whatever you marked it
would also delete your main gun and it
didn't tell you that that was equipped
or that was your best gun there wasn't
like a warning hey you're about to
delete your favorite whatever so like
these quality of life improvements give
the game the potential that if the next
DLC has enough content that people will
stick around after that and continue the
the leveling grind and they might enjoy
the lower time to kill and like just a
general shooting better so it's it's an
opportunity for them that being said I
don't know the first DLC will just
should have been called a room like DLC
the room because that's all it was their
incursion was just like a place you walk
into you saw the boss right away it was
just standing there yeah and the only
thing that that mode did was flush you
out of cover and a cover based shooter
continuously until you killed the thing
at the other end of the room and it just
wasn't wasn't compelling so in terms of
the actual progression this seems like
it like you had mentioned it might be
more like we're gonna talk about rise of
iron later it seems like it's more of a
gradual grind kind of in terms of
regression and like you said not someone
that's been maxing and actually knowing
exactly what item to get and how to kind
of maximize that items capabilities now
it's more of if you want to play
casually a lot you you will build your
character yeah go kill bola King once a
day you can go do the new underground
DLC which i think is probably the best
way to get loot um for casual players
again like you just go through it you
get great loot every day and the dark
zone i think is still kind of a mess
like i don't know why i would play the
dark zone as opposed to underground dlc
because i'm guaranteed loot in the
underground where's the dark zone you
work really hard and then somebody just
kind of shoots you in the back yeah and
then they even patch it so like even if
you get your stuff on the line you get
away they can still just come back and
cut the line take your stuff
but it's hard to tell they started
everybody off in the public test server
with a base character it was a base
level character mm-hmm so nobody's
gotten their new vector or whatever yet
so we still can't tell maybe the dark
zone is still pretty busted won't be
able to know for a couple weeks until
people get the the new stuff again yeah
I mean I only played a few hours of this
game and the reason I liked it and I
think the reason I was initially
appealing to me before it released was
just the game world this decrepit in New
York City net you know like you had
spent a lot of time when you're younger
not at the crap in new york city of New
York City no decrepit New York City yeah
you hung out in the slums and as you
would but no we uh that's I think this
is what I've been waiting for the dlc
was never interesting to me some like
big revamp that would actually make the
game fun to me yeah was what I was
waiting for so I'm wondering it doesn't
sound like this is enough but maybe I'll
still try go back and play an hour and
see if it's like grabbing me but I mean
we have a lot of games coming out but
the division was all is the one this
year that I feel like I didn't give a
chance I don't know are you interested
in going back at all yes now I me not
because I did try to give it a chance i
spent like maybe three to four hours
with the game and i sort of the problems
I described earlier were the things that
turned me off but yes the world is
interesting i like the concept of people
sort of like meeting in this camp to
like go out on these missions like
that's all great so yeah like if the
sort of like small moment-to-moment
stuff is improved in streamlined and
made just to feel more fun I i could see
wanting to play it again but it for me
it's almost like that time has passed
which sucks because there are so many
good games that are just good no matter
when you try to play them but yeah the
division I mean I'd feel like I'd have
to start over in this point so it would
have to do a lot to give me to start
over it's interesting because I mean you
mentioned starting over I think when
taken king came out a lot of us were
jealous of people who maybe never played
destiny before yeah because they were
getting the full experience they were
getting the originally the most of the
most of what the original design was for
that game yeah and that's how I
understood the division I thought
Ubisoft was making more of a platform
kind of to maybe like once a year like
destiny released its expansion or like
that's actually going to revamp things
and kind of change how you think the
game works and how the game works and
like not mechanics but the actual
systems at play and I think that's what
I'm waiting for for the division and
this doesn't seem substantial enough I
mean it's only in public test server is
right now but doesn't seem substantial
enough for me to jump back in
especially like with other games on the
horizon but I don't know I kind of like
the DLC just doesn't appeal to me
because again that's just the same game
with more content especially judging by
the room it doesn't sound like there's
much promise there and also the public
test servers aren't always necessarily
for that game the battlefield 4 public
test server realistically was to make
the next battlefield game better and
division did sell extremely well and
this may be for them to fix everything
for the next division game I mean I
don't they could walk at this point I
think it would still be a success at
least financially for their company and
they could make a better sequel if they
wanted to learning from the public test
in the meantime yeah well that is the
update 1.4 public test servers the
update is not officially out yet that's
available on you play and it will be on
steam at some point you soft has not
said when yet but they said it will be
soon so go check that out and let us
think let us know what you think in the
comments below